[Music]
foreign
and this is life liberty and Levin
Saturday
I'm sure glad you found us tell your
friends and family and you can always
record us on the DVR
ladies and gentlemen there are many
issues confronting this nation that are
grave and dire to the people of this
nation but I want to focus on two
we have two great guests tonight and I
want to discuss it with them too
Senator Ted Cruz and Congressman Byron
Donalds but before we get to them
you know the situation with immigration
I don't even know why we call it
immigration anymore it's not immigration
like we have some kind of managed system
for people to emigrate to the United
States and we politely call them
immigrants or people without documents
and so forth we have a full-fledged
Invasion going on
as a result of the purposeful and
intentional inaction
of the Biden regime
it's intentional what's going on on that
southern border and what's going on
death
almost 800 people have died on that
border we have sex trafficking and not
just of grown women of children it's
grotesque we have fentanyl other lethal
drugs pouring into the country and
killing up to a hundred thousand
Americans every single year
we have murders we have rapists coming
across the border people who've been
deported nine times 11 times 14 times
back in the country we have drug cartels
that now have footholds in every single
state of the union
now this is unsustainable
I understand that some democrat Mayors
are now upset some democratic Governors
are now upset where the hell have they
been
you look at these border states what's
going on well they've turned Arizona
blue
they've turned Nevada blue
they've turned New Mexico blue some of
these were at least competitive States
they're turning Georgia Blue
they've turned Virginia purple towards
blue
and their main goal is to take out Texas
because as I've said before once Texas
goes blue the nation goes blue and
there's no turning back either under the
popular vote or the Electoral College
this Democrat Party is all about power
it could care less about the inhumanity
that's going on on that border Kamala
Harris doesn't give a damn this is
partly her assignment we'll look at her
assignment and then we have to hear from
these Democrats like Gavin Newsom one of
the worst governors in the history of
any state
tell us that she's qualified she's been
there Nancy Pelosi she's qualified
Kamala Harris and if you dare to
question her oh
you're either misogynist or a racist
well of course that's the fallback
position if not the frontal position
in his
412-year career in Washington D.C Joe
Biden's been to the Border once and even
then
he saw potemkin Village they cleaned out
the streets they cleaned out the cages
and the detention centers and you
Shuffle around and he's wondering what
the problem is they keep certain border
patrol away from him so they can't
complain to him and that's that
then we have a cabinet secretary this
mayorkas who tells us the board is
secure
have you ever seen anybody tell a bigger
lie in your life
while he oversees and he knows exactly
what's taking place on that border
and so this is the Democrat Party this
is not nature doing this this is a
Democrat Party doing this
and then there's another issue front and
center spending
spending in the next few days the debate
will be whether the House Republicans
shut down the government or not
we're the Senate Republicans matter of
fact in this whole immigration issue and
Border issue we're the Senate
Republicans
what are they proposing
are they using their power they have a
lot of power in the Senate
they have the filibuster power they have
the budget power
they can influence and affect all these
issues where's Mitch McConnell is he
still with us
and how about the others that surround
Mitch McConnell where are they
corn and thune barrasso and the rest of
them
are they just placeholders
the majority of the Republicans in the
Senate they say nothing they do nothing
and then when they run for office they
don't have any principal position so
what do they do they blame us
when they can't get a majority and a
majority to do what look at the budget
situation what is the position
of the Senate Republicans when it comes
to spending debt and the budget their
position is to support Schumer
and what is Schumer's position remember
they cut a deal in May the Republicans
and and Biden and the rest
Schumer has gone back on the deal he's
blown the Caps that is the spending
limits off the deal that was set in fact
they want to spend an enormous amount of
additional money
they don't want to secure the Border
there's nothing in there to secure the
Border
they're undermining the United States
military I could go on and on with their
budget priorities their budget
priorities are to redistribute wealth
and they keep pouring trillions of
dollars into the fourth branch of
government their bureaucracy their
permanent government
let me read you something about that out
of my new book the Democrat Party hates
America and thank you who have acquired
your copy or are acquiring your copies
in May 2023 the government
accountability office the GAO released a
report titled the nation's fiscal health
which received almost no attention
it said the federal government faces an
unsustainable long-term fiscal future
at the end of fiscal year 2022 debt held
by the public was about 97 percent of
gross domestic product
projections from The Office of
Management and budget
at the Department of Treasury the
Congressional budget office and the GAO
they all got together
all show that current fiscal policy is
unsustainable over the long term these
are government bureaucrats responsible
for watching the fiscal state of the
country
some of which are attached to Congress
some of which are attached to the
executive branch one of which is
independent all saying the same thing
dead Hell by the public has projected to
grow at a faster Pace than the size of
the economy
that's getting big we are being
swallowed by the debt we're in a debt
spiral right now that is the death null
of all Nations just like open borders
and the destruction of citizenship and
sovereignty
these are the two biggies the death null
of a Nation
the report finds that the fiscal year
2022 Federal deficit was among the
highest in American history 2022
this occurred even though Revenue growth
has been strong and federal covid-19
relief spending has declined from recent
years in addition the cost of financing
of that increase from prior years
because interest rates Rose
substantially in fiscal year 2022 in
other words a huge percentage
of the budget is now going to paying
interest on the accumulated debt
it's only going to get bigger Rising
debt relative to economic growth could
increase borrowing costs for both the
federal government and private borrowers
and could slow economic growth CBO has
stated that high and Rising federal debt
as they share the economy increases the
risk of a fiscal crisis
the underlying conditions driving the
unsustainable fiscal Outlook post
serious Economic Security and Social
Challenges if not addressed this is the
federal government talking to itself
so what is the position of the
Republicans in the Senate on this issue
you've gone along with Schumer they
don't have a single proposal to address
this
oh we need a continuing resolution to do
what continuing
considering resolution to do this now
what's interesting is that report looks
back at 2022.
the greatest deficit in American history
they said in 2022 well guess what's
happened in 2023
that deficit has doubled to two trillion
dollars it's now the biggest deficit in
American history this year on top of the
second biggest deficit in American
history last year hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else